Hello Freak bitches.
If you didn't work with people because
of their private life and things you
didn't agree with,
you would never work with anybody.
What you imagine their mess,
you have to sit down with them and go
over their private life.
Okay.
Have you ever lied to a cop?
Right?
Right.
Have you ever lied about speeding,
but you ever not paid your taxes?
Now let's get into your sex life.
Do you ever think about other people
when you come?
Okay,
this meeting is over.
I had a buddy of mine that actually got
an argument like that with his
girlfriend.
She was like,
my friend says that guy's fantasize
about other women while they're having
sex with your girlfriend.
Is that true?
And he was like,
well sometimes she's like,
you fucking piece of shit.
She got really mad at him.
Right.
And I'm like,
when I,
I don't remember thinking about it like,
why do you care?
I guess if your wife was just thinking
about just getting stuffed by some big
ass country football player,
some big dude with like chewing tobacco
in his mouth and a fucking rebel flag
hat on.
He's just laying pipe on her and that's
what you're thinking about when you
fucker,
she's thinking about some corn Fred.
Imagine,
right?
Yeah.
But it'd be like,
Oh fuck man.
But that's why you don't ask the
question.
That's why you don't ask.
You'll probably,
there probably is happening,
but you don't ask if,
if you really love your wife,
you want to know everything about her.
You want to know everything when she's
disappointed.
Oh my God,
you,
I love you honey.
But I hate that face you make when you
come.
You make me disgusted.
That's why I'm all fuck you.
You just walk into the kitchen in the
morning,
honey,
what are you thinking?
So next time you fucker just wear a
luchador mask or even better yet,
like Godzilla.
Oh,
rubber Godzilla.
Hey,
fantasies are weird man.
Because like I can't,
I remember when I was in high school,
there was a,
a,
a guy who was writing for the Newton
south high school paper who wrote this
cool thing about the boy scouts.
And I remember reading this because I
was in the boy scouts briefly as a young
teenager and they have,
you know the tenants like trustworthy,
loyal,
thrifty,
clean,
reverent and like one of the things
about what the voice boy scouts were
supposed to do is keep your mind pure,
right?
Keep your thoughts pure.
And this guy was like,
who wrote this article?
And obviously this is in high school in
the 1980s guy was pretty brilliant and
he was like,
I don't like the idea of anyone telling
me what I can and can't do with my
thoughts because sometimes my thoughts
are fun.
Right.
I like to explore the idea of thinking
about and his argument in this newspaper
and I'm like grossly paraphrasing him
cause again this is like from 1982 or
something like that.
He was like you like you don't need to
know what's going on in my thoughts.
You just needed to know how I act,
how I act is important,
not what I think.
So tell me to keep my thoughts pure.
It's like my thoughts are mine right
there.
Mine.
I do what want with them.
That's right.
So if you girlfriend is just thinking
about that big country fucker,
a piece of wheat coming out of the
corner of his mouth,
Nazi Tattoo on the back of his neck,
just laying good dick.
God bless her fat Dick.
God bless her,
whatever she's into like a sailor's
forearm.
I am not asking.
Yeah,
I mean,
do you have moments like in your
relationship where you know you're with
each other for your life?
This is,
this is a long time thing.
I feel like we should meet and the
Seattle music.
It was when you're all of a sudden,
oh no,
no,
do it.
Jamie went to get some incredible hulk
walkaway music and there's times when
you were into her and that's it.
There's times when you know there's
times when all of a sudden you,
you about to say this times when she's
not in the EU.
Yes.
Unacceptable walk.
Be a man.
Suck it up.
There's times not that psyched with me
right now to Casey knee Tan with a
boner.
You chew to Viagra.
You get your Dick hard as a rock.
I'm not saying you don't do those
things.
What I'm saying is you don't ask her why
you don't ask what?
What is it like?
You don't want to know these things.
I don't want to know why she's unhappy.
I want to know.
I just want her to keep her thoughts to
herself.
If she's bang some big redneck in a
truck stop.
No,
you don't want,
I don't want anything.
You don't want to know if she's actually
being or thinking about bang.
I don't want to know anything.
You don't want anything?
Oh No.
What a good husband.
You want her to just be a good mom,
a good wife and eat my bread and eat.
And how about she cooks something once
in a while.
Why my baking bread?
Like I'm an old lady.
Why am I running around with a flower on
my shirt?
Okay.